[موسيقى]
من غابة الغابة
إلى ناطحات السحاب في مركز كوالالمبور
مليون مقيم هنا تزدهر الأعمال التجارية
على الأطراف 7 ملايين شخص آخر في
جميع أنحاء العالم تستهلك المباني والبناء أكثر من ثلث الطاقة الإجمالية
وغالبًا ما يتم التغاضي عن حقيقة
هذا هو أول مبنى أخضر به
لوحة رقم 18 في هذه البلدة على
بعد 40 كيلومترًا خارج كوالالمبور والتي
تعمل الآن كمخطط للآخرين
لاتباع مبادئها تم تطبيقها لأول مرة من
قبل المهندس المعماري ولوك مون
على منزله عن طريق وضع
مكيف الهواء من الأرضية التي
يوفرها  كان المبنى حوالي 30 إلى 50 في
المائة ، كنا مشغولين للغاية في ماليزيا في
بناء الأمة لدرجة أنه لم يخطر ببالنا أبدًا
أننا احتجنا أيضًا إلى
الاهتمام بالبيئة ، عندما أطلقنا
مؤشر المباني الخضراء ، كان عام 2009 هو العام ولن
أدرك أن هناك طريقة أخرى  للنظر
إلى الأشياء وقد ساعد أيضًا في تحقيق النتيجة النهائية ، حيث
انخفضت تكاليف التشغيل
تمامًا ، ورفعت الطاقة القديمة إلى مستوى مرتفع ،
وقد يكون النجاح المستقبلي لهذه المدينة أكثر أهمية
خصص ظل أبراج بتروناس
هيكلًا من الخيزران من قبل المهندس المعماري الحائز على جائزة
ألينا جميل الذي التقينا به في
مهرجان العمارة لهذا الشهر ،
نتحرك ببطء نحو صنع
مواد طبيعية مستدامة تُترك من خلال التحرك
لتصبح مادة بناء قياسية
لاستخدامها في المباني في الإسكان  في
المباني الشاهقة وناطحات السحاب التي
تستجيب للمناخ أمر مهم للغاية في مناخ
حار ورطب مثل ماليزيا ، ثم
ترى أنه في
التعليم المعماري ترى الطلاب يصممون
مبانٍ حساسة
تستجيب للمناخ مما يجعل الاتصال
بالثقافة المحلية والمحلية
نمط الحياة تدريبك على الجيل القادم
من المهندسين المعماريين ، هل
رأوا العالم بشكل مختلف عما كنت عليه في
أيامك الأولى من الدراسة ،
قد ينقذ الجيل الجديد العالم الذي
يفهمون أن الحرارة المكتسبة من
خلال المنزل تكون مهيمنة من خلال
السقف وكل هذه الأمور الآن  ذهبت إلى
النادي ولدي أمل كبير في أن
الجيل الجديد سيفعل الشيء الصحيح
جي  ohn حمامة تيريوس سي إن إن كوالالمبور